that's pretty much for both the outer
journey and inner journey level how
stage 1 and stage 2 work now we come to
the second key turning point what I call
the change of plans this is the moment
when the hero has now formulated the
goal they want to achieve in his case
he's going to get the best plea bargain
he can for these defendants and they
begin pursuing it now the point to
notice if you're a screenwriter a
filmmaker or even if you're a novelist
that whatever the outer motivation
whatever this visible goal your hero is
going to pursue that defines your movie
your hero shouldn't start actually
pursuing it and taking action to cross
that finish line until the beginning of
act 2 you got to take an entire 25% of
your screenplay just to build up to your
hero taking those first steps everything
up to now has been him gathering
information to figure out what are we
going to do
it's only when he takes that first step
of going to hunt on ammo that he's now
moving toward the goal and this is stage
3 what I call progress because his plan
is okay I'm gonna get the facts and I'm
gonna juggle them around and figure out
a way that I can get them off with the
least sentence possible and that's when
he meets another key character in the
story and that is his nemesis that's my
term for the person who is it cross
purposes with the hero if the reflection
is there to help the hero the Nemesis is
the one who wants to stop the hero from
achieving his goal he's the one in
opposition he's the villain in this case
more like a villain but he could be an
opponent if it's a sports story or it
could be a rival if it's a love story or
romantic comedy but it's somebody who
goes against the villain and when we
meet Jessup that's the Jack Nicholson
character a few things are apparent
immediately one is he is way more
powerful than Cathy is this is a must
when you're writing a screenplay or a
story of any kind you always want your
nemesis to exceed your hero in their
power and abilities and strength and so
on it must seem like it's going to be
impossible for your hero to overcome the
nemesis
so Jessop has all the power all the rank
he puts caffee down caffee is like sort
of meek with him and Shia and just wants
to get out of the situation he seems
almost wimpy in the face of Nathan
jessep which is exactly as it should be
because now we're involved now we
realize the conflict is big and the
bigger the conflict the more our
emotional involvement in the story so he
starts working and working and working
towards caffee does toward figuring out
or putting together his defense for them
now on the inner journey level remember
he's got this tug of war going on
between his identity his safe persona
that keeps him stuck in a place that is
familiar in his comfort zone but he's
not going to lead to any fulfillment and
by the way I don't think I mentioned
this the rule is if the hero doesn't
move into his essence if the hero is not
able to shed his identity and have the
courage to live his truth he cannot
achieve the goal he doesn't realize that
the hero at this point in the story
thinks he'll pursue this goal so he can
keep his identity in place but it will
always follow because you as the writer
are gonna make it this way that unless
the hero finds the courage to leave his
identity he's not going to get that goal
so now your hero is vacillating moving
into his essence a bit because he's got
to move closer to the goal but that
becomes very scary because he's lost his
armor his emotional protection is gone
so then he'll retreat and go back into
his identity so you'll see when you
watch the movie or if you watch the
movie again as you watch this during
this stretch caffee is at times gonna
seem like a really good lawyer he's
gonna do smart things he's gonna figure
out things he's gonna know how to
manipulate things not Cathy but some of
the other characters he's coming up with
ideas
other times he just wants to back off
just get a plea bargain or whatever
until finally when he realizes these
defendants are not cooperating at all he
says I can't understand these guys I'm
gonna quit I'm gonna get the lawyer
replaced and he makes that threat right
before
we reach the next key turning point what
I call the point of no return
you